>> THE LIFE OF A TOP MODEL
CAN BE A FANTASY COME TRUE...
LEARNING TO PROWL THE CATWALK,
ENJOYING THE GLITZ
AND THE GLAMOUR.
BUT BECOMING A TOP MODEL
IS A LOT MORE THAN
A SASSY STRUT
OR DAZZLING PHOTOS.
IT'S A STUNNING TRANSFORMATION
THAT ONLY A FEW LUCKY GIRLS
WILL EXPERIENCE.
FOR OUR SEVENTH CYCLE,
OUR SEARCH
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
TOOK US TO SMALL TOWNS
AND BIG CITIES
TO GIVE 13 PROMISING GIRLS
A CHANCE TO SHINE.
>> ♪ AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL ♪
♪ PLEASE PICK ME ♪
>> THE SEMIFINALISTS
FLEW TO LOS ANGELES,
BUT ONCE THE PLANE LANDED,
IT WAS TIME
TO PUT THE GAME FACE IN PLACE.
(needle scratching record)
>> AAH!
>> FIRST, THE INTERVIEW...
OH, YOUR NAME IS MELISSA ROSE,
BUT YOU GO BY WHAT?
>> MELROSE.
>> WHY IS THAT?
>> I DON'T NEED THAT "ISSA."
>> YES!
DROP IT LIKE IT'S HOT.
DROP, DROP. OKAY, KEEP TALKING.
>> LIKE THAT?
>> YEAH!
FROM FANCY FOOTWORK
TO MODELS WHO RAP.
Y'ALL GOT THE BEAT?
>> ♪ INTELLIGENT AND CLASSY ♪
♪ I GOT A CUTE LITTLE BOOTY ♪
♪ NOT ONLY BRAINS ♪
♪ I GOT THE BEAUTY ♪
♪ OH ♪
>> ♪ OH ♪
♪ HEY ♪
>> AND THEN IT WAS TIME
TO BARE IT ALL
IN THIS REVEALING PHOTO SHOOT.
>> TODAY YOU GIRLS
ARE GOING TO BE SHOOTING...
NUDE.
>> AAH!
♪♪
>> THERE WAS GOOD NEWS
FOR THE GIRLS
THAT MADE THE FINAL CUT...
ANCHAL.
>> OH, MY GOD! YES!
>> A.J.
>> HELL YEAH! WHOO!
>> AND BAD NEWS
AS REALITY HIT HOME.
GIVE ME A HUG.
IN THE END, I INVITED
ONLY 13 GIRLS TO MOVE
INTO THEIR "TOP MODEL" HOUSE
AND LIVE THEIR DREAM.
>> (cheering)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> NOW ONLY
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN--
MELROSE,
EUGENA,
CARIDEE,
JAEDA,
AMANDA,
MICHELLE
AND ANCHAL.
TONIGHT,
WE'LL SEE THE BEST MOMENTS FROM
THEIR "TOP MODEL" JOURNEY...
>> (growls)
>> AS WELL AS THE WORST,
PLUS NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN
SPECIAL MOMENTS
YOU WON'T WANT TO MISS.
>> WHERE ARE MY DORITOS?!
>> THERE'S FOOD THERE,
THERE'S FOOD THERE,
THERE'S FOOD THERE!
>> FROM MODELS IN DISTRESS...
>> BIRD!
>> AAH!
(screaming)
>> TO LESS THAN MODEL BEHAVIOR.
>> WHAT YOU ARE DOING?
YOU'RE SO WEIRD!
>> IS THIS MY TACO SEASONING?
>> PLEASE, JUST STOP!
YOU'RE SO WEIRD!
OH, MY GOD, GET AWAY FROM ME!
>> ♪ YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP? ♪
♪♪
>> THE TOP 13
ARRIVED IN HOLLYWOOD
WITH STARS IN THEIR EYES...
>> (cheering)
>> MOVING INTO THIS
FASHION MAGAZINE-THEMED
HILLSIDE MANSION.
>> IT'S KIND OF LIKE
A TYRA MAGAZINE THEME
FOR THE WHOLE HOUSE.
>> OH, MY GOD,
THIS IS FREAKIN' BEAUTIFUL.
>> THIS IS "TOP MODEL," BABY,
"TOP MODEL"!
>> (cheering)
>> FOR THEIR
VERY FIRST CHALLENGE,
I WANTED THE GIRLS
TO ROCK THE RUNWAY
WEARING A CLOTHING LINE
MADE FOR MEN.
>> HIT IT!
>> THEY'RE DEFINITELY
ROCK 'N' ROLL STYLE.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD--
KIND OF WOULD
GIVE ME AN ADVANTAGE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M SO USED TO.
>> MELROSE TURNED UP THE VOLUME
AND WON THE CHALLENGE.
>> MELROSE, WE THOUGHT YOU DID
AN EXCELLENT JOB
WITH THE CLOTHES.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH!
>> BUT WHAT YOU NEVER SAW
WAS WHEN THE GIRLS
GOT BACK HOME.
IT WAS TIME TO SHAKE THINGS UP
WITH THIS WARDROBE RAID.
>> FIRST OFF,
I'M CHARLIE ALTUNA,
AND I'LL BE YOUR
WARDROBE STYLIST
FOR ALL OF YOUR SHOOTS.
>> (cheering)
>> YEAH!
>> AND MY NAME IS SUTAN.
IT'S SO NICE TO MEET YOU GIRLS.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
I AM ACTUALLY
YOUR MAKEUP ARTIST.
>> YEAH!
>> RIGHT.
WHAT WE REALLY WANNA DO
IS ACTUALLY,
WE WANT TO SEE YOUR CLOTHES.
>> WE NEED YOU GUYS TO GO
GET YOUR LUGGAGE RIGHT NOW,
LINE UP AND SET IT UP.
>> RUN!
>> AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"WE'RE HAVING A FASHION RAID."
I WAS NOT REALLY HAPPY.
>> OH, NO,
HE'S GOT THE FASHION TRASH!
>> WE'RE FREAKING OUT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A FASHION TRASH CAN...
>> THIS IS HIDEOUS, ACTUALLY.
>> IT WAS MY MOM'S.
>> AND THEY ARE
THROWING THINGS IN IT.
>> NO.
>> OH!
>> WHOO!
>> I WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU HAVE.
>> OKAY, SO THIS IS LIKE
A FROG THREW UP ALL OVER IT.
>> I'M FEELING IT MYSELF.
>> THIS IS A DISCO BALL
WALKING DOWN THE STREET.
>> THOSE ARE $200!
>> THESE ARE FOR DRAG QUEENS
AND DRAG QUEENS ALONE.
>> MONIQUE'S BOOTS
ARE FASHION TRASH TO ME.
THEY DESERVE TO GO IN THE TRASH.
>> IS THIS AN OUTFIT?
>> NO, THAT'S A TOWEL.
>> OH, OKAY.
(laughter)
>> Y'ALL ARE NOT COOL.
>> MELROSE.
GORGEOUS. "A" PLUS.
>> I MADE A LOT OF THE CLOTHES
THAT I'M WEARING HERE,
SO I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT
IN MY CLOTHES.
>> ADORABLE.
GIRL, YOU GOT--YOU'RE GOOD.
YOU GOT AN "A" PLUS, MELROSE.
(bell dings)
>> DUDE, WHY DOES
EVERYTHING YOU HAVE
HAVE RHINESTONES ON IT?
>> THIS IS, LIKE,
14-YEAR-OLD GIRL.
WE GOTTA GET RID OF IT.
>> UGH, THAT'S LIKE A DOILY.
THAT GOES--
HONEY, THAT GOES OVER THE COUCH
LIKE THAT.
LATER ON IN YOUR CAREERS
WHEN YOU BECOME
REALLY BIG MODELS,
YOU'RE GONNA THANK
THE TWO GAY GUYS
THAT CAME IN HERE
AND RAIDED YOUR SUITCASES.
>> WE'LL SEE YOU SOON.
>> NO!
>> GIVE IT BACK!
(laughter)
>> COME ON, CARI!
(shouting over each other)
>> NO, STOP IT!
>> GIVE IT BACK!
>> BUT SOME PEOPLE GOT, LIKE,
$200 OF STUFF WORTH THROWN AWAY,
SO I WAS LIKE,
OOH, THIS ISN'T FUNNY.
>> AFTER TOSSING OUT THE OLD,
IT WAS TIME TO GO SHOPPING
FOR SOMETHING NEW.
>> WELCOME TO skyla!
>> (cheering)
>> THIS IS L.A.'s NEWEST
AND HOTTEST SHOPPING SPOT.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> YOU GIRLS ARE ITCHING,
READY TO SHOP, RIGHT?
>> YEAH!
>> I WAS EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
I'M LIKE, NEW CLOTHES!
IT WAS GREAT.
>> BUT BEFORE YOU GET
YOUR LITTLE--
GRUBBY LITTLE GREEDY PALMS
ALL OVER EVERYTHING
IN THE STORE,
THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT WITH TYRA,
OR THINGS THAT SHE WANTED US
TO DISCUSS WITH YOU
AS FAR AS WHAT ARE MODEL BASICS.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO LOOK
FOR THINGS THAT YOU NEED
RATHER THAN WHAT YOU WANT,
AND THOSE THINGS ARE...
>> YOU DEFINITELY NEED
A SHORT, LITTLE MINISKIRT.
(bell dings)
>> YOU NEED
A NUDE BRA AND PANTY,
A LARGE GORGEOUS BAG THAT
YOU'LL KEEP YOUR PORTFOLIO IN,
TANK TOP,
A HAIR SCRUNCHIE OR SOMETHING
TO TIE YOUR HAIR BACK,
A GORGEOUS FITTED PAIR OF JEANS,
BLACK LITTLE COCKTAIL DRESS
AND A CUTE PAIR
OF LITTLE SNEAKS.
>> THERE'S A REALLY
MAJOR CHALLENGE.
YOU HAVE A TIME LIMIT OF ONLY...
>> FIVE MINUTES.
>> WHAT?!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> FIVE MINUTES.
>> SHOP WISELY.
>> IT'S LIKE EVERY GIRL'S DREAM
TO GO IN A STORE
AND GET FIVE MINUTES
TO GRAB WHATEVER YOU WANT.
I MEAN, COME ON.
>> SHOP!
>> COME ON, FIVE MINUTES!
(bell dings)
>> OH, THAT HOLDS
YOUR PORTFOLIO...
>> REMEMBER YOUR BASICS!
>> WHEN YOU'RE JOGGING
AROUND TOWN.
(bell dings)
>> ALL RIGHT,
THAT'S PERFECT, GIRL.
MOVE ON, MOVE ON.
>> JUST ME MODELING
BEFORE I GOT ON THIS,
I ALREADY HAD
EVERYTHING THEY ASKED FOR.
>> GOOD GIRL. GOOD.
(bell dings)
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> AAH!
>> IT WAS LIKE A MADHOUSE.
WE WERE JUST DASHING AROUND,
PEOPLE WERE GRABBING STUFF.
AND DID STUFF END UP
ON THE FLOOR?
OH, YOU BELIEVE IT.
>> I WANT A BLACK ONE.
(cat growls)
(bell dings)
(buzzer sounds)
>> ARE YOU SURE
THAT'S A BASIC, GIRL?
(bell dings)
>> TWO MINUTES!
>> WOW, YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU GOT A LOT, GIRL.
>> I THINK I DID.
>> YOU'RE DOING GOOD.
(bell dings)
(buzzer sounds)
>> ONE MINUTE!
YOU GOT ONE MINUTE LEFT!
>> NOW I SEE SOME THINGS
IN YOUR HANDS
THAT ARE NOT MODEL BASICS,
LIKE A PURPLE-Y SATINY DRESS.
(buzzer sounds)
>> TEN, NINE, EIGHT...
>> AAH!
>> I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL I'M DOING.
THEY HAD FOUR T-SHIRTS LEFT
AND, LIKE, A COUPLE WIFEBEATERS.
EVERYTHING ELSE GOT TAKEN.
>> FOUR, THREE, TWO...
>> THAT'S IT!
>> STOP! STOP!
>> STOP SHOPPING!
>> SHOPPING WAS A HUGE SUCCESS.
I GOT EVERYTHING I WANTED,
EVERYTHING I NEEDED.
>> AND WE'D LIKE TO SAY
A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO SKYLA
FOR ALLOWING US
A REALLY FABULOUS
SHOPPING AFTERNOON.
>> YEP. YEAH.
>> THANK YOU!
>> THE SHOPPING SPREE
WAS A DREAM,
BUT BACK AT THE HOUSE,
MELROSE'S BOSSY BEHAVIOR
WAS BECOMING A NIGHTMARE.
>> BEFORE YOU USE
ANYTHING IN THIS KITCHEN,
I WOULD RECOMMEND CLEANING IT.
>> MELROSE HAS TRIED TO BE
THE MOM OF THE HOUSE,
WHICH A LOT OF PEOPLE
AREN'T FEELING.
>> OKAY, THE RULE IS
I'M MAKING THIS FOR EVERYONE,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA
CLEAN THE DISHES, OKAY?
>> FOR MONIQUE AND MELROSE,
THE RIVALRY WAS ON.
>> HEY, GUYS!
MELROSE ALWAYS
HAS SOMETHING TO SAY.
LIKE, SHE'S ALWAYS TALKING.
"IS THIS A PIECE OF PAPER
ON THE FLOOR?
WHY IS THERE A PAPER
WHERE'S MY COFFEE?
WHERE IS MY COFFEE?
DON'T EVER LITTER! DON'T LITTER!
YOU SHOULD DO THIS...
YOU SHOULDN'T GET THIS BOOK.
AND YOU SHOULDN'T
USE THAT PRODUCT.
YOU SHOULD USE THIS PRODUCT.
YOU SHOULDN'T WEAR
THOSE DAMN PANTIES, OKAY?
COTTON ISN'T GOOD.
YOU SHOULD WEAR SILK.
SILK, SILK, SILK.
AND YOU SHOULDN'T EAT THAT ONE.
YOU SHOULD EAT THIS.
WHO USES VEGETABLE OIL?
IT JUST CLOGS THEIR PORES
AND YOUR BODY
AND YOUR JUST GONNA DIE!"
I'M LIKE, "GOSH, YOU ALWAYS
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY.
JUST SHUT UP."
(giggles) GUYS!
>> MONIQUE, WHAT'D THEY SLIP
INTO YOUR BREAKFAST
THIS MORNING?
>> THAT SMELLS SO GOOD.
>> YOU CAN HAVE SOME.
>> (whispers) SHE SAID
IT SMELLS GOOD.
AMAZING!
(normal voice) I JUST
CAN'T STAND HER.
I'M TIRED OF IT.
I CAN'T STAND
TO JUST HEAR HER VOICE.
>> EW, MAKE ME SICK.
>> (laughs) I JUST MAKE YOU
SO SICK.
DIE, BITCH, DIE.
>> (laughs silently)
>> (grunting)
>> YOU'RE JUST
HATING ON YOURSELF.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> WHO THE HELL
HATES ON THEIRSELF?
LIKE, THAT'S A NEW ONE.
"YOU'RE JUST HATING
ON YOURSELF."
>> I DEFINITELY
AM NOT INTERESTED
IN HAVING A FRIENDSHIP
WITH MONIQUE EVER.
>> BEFORE THEIR
VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
I GAVE THE GIRLS
MY BEST IMPRESSION
OF THE WORST KIND
OF MODEL BEHAVIOR.
(French accent) WHERE IS
THE PHOTOGRAPHER?
(laughter)
>> I AM THE QUEEN!
WHAT? WHERE IS MY WIND?!
>> WE'RE GONNA GET THE--
>> WHERE?! WHERE IS MY WIND?!
>> WHAT, WHAT, WHAT?
WHAT, WHAT, WHAT?
I'VE TOLD YOU
THIS WOMAN NEEDS WIND!
>> MISS TYRA,I WON'T DO IT
AGAIN, TYRA.
>> CONSTANTLY!
>> WHEN I GO TO THE TROPICS...
>> GIRLS, HELP ME BLOW.
>> I NEED WIND!
>> WE NEED THE WIND!
>> THEN IT WAS THEIR TURN
TO BRING MODEL STEREOTYPES
TO LIFE.
>> MY STEREOTYPE IS
BLACK GIRLS
WHO GET IN THE INDUSTRY
AND THEY WANT TO BE WHITE.
>> UP ON THIS, PLEASE.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE BARBIE.
OH, I LOVE THAT!
JUST KEEP DOING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
YOU LOOK GREAT.
IT'S GENIUS.
JUST A LITTLE TOO
LUCILLE BALL AND ZANY.
>> ACTION.
>> NICE.
>> LET'S SEE THE EMOTION.
YOU'RE CRAZY ABOUT HIM!
COME ON, LET ME SEE IT!
>> FROM CASTING TO NOW,
I THINK CHRISTIAN'S
GIVEN ME THE SAME THING--
BROKE-DOWN TYRA BANKS.
>> GOT THE GIRL?
>> WE'RE READY FOR MELROSE.
OKAY, MELROSE, WHAT'S THE ISSUE?
I'VE BEEN WAITING HERE.
>> OH, HONEY...
(chuckles) I'VE BEEN READY
FOR, LIKE, SIX HOURS.
>> THE ATTITUDE RIGHT NOW?
JUST LISTEN--
DON'T SLOW UP THE SHOOTS.
IS THAT HORRIFIED,
OR IS THAT BAD ACTING?
>> (laughs) IT'S BAD ACTING.
>> YEAH, THANK YOU.
CAN YOU GIVE ME HORRIFIED?
>> AAH!
>> MELROSE PLAYED
QUEEN BEE OF THE HOUSE,
BUT AT JUDGING
SHE HIT ROCK BOTTOM.
>> WHAT WORRIES ME
IN A SHOT LIKE THIS IS THAT
YOU PHOTOGRAPH LOOKING OLD.
>> YOU WERE LATE FOR THE SHOOT,
AND YOU WERE
THE WORST OF THE DAY.
WHILE CHRISTIAN'S PHOTO
REVEALED THAT SHE WAS
NOT UP TO THE CHALLENGE.
>> THE PHOTO JUST
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME.
>> I WASN'T SURE IF A WAS
GRASPING THE CONCEPT TOO WELL.
>> IF THEY SAY,
"BE A BAD ACTRESS,"
GO FOR IT AND BE A BAD ACTRESS.
"OH! OH!"
YOU KNOW, OVER-THE-TOP.
AND CHRISTIAN WAS THE FIRST
TO BE SENT HOME.
>> (crying) OH, MY GOSH!
>> (crying)
I REALLY FELT LIKE
I HAD MORE POTENTIAL
THAN MELROSE.
I REALLY WISH
I COULD TURN BACK TIME.
I COULD'VE GONE FAR
IN THE COMPETITION.
>> COMING UP--
AMANDA TAKES ON MONIQUE
IN A NEVER-BEFORE SEEN
SHOWDOWN.
>> THERE'S FOOD THERE,
THERE'S FOOD THERE,
THERE'S FOOD THERE!
>> AND LATER,
THE GIRLS TRY TO WALK ON WATER.
>> (cheering)
>> IN THE WORLD OF MODELING,
CHANGE IS PART
OF THE BUSINESS,
SO THIS SEASON
I SET UP A FULL SALON
IN THE "TOP MODEL" HOUSE
FOR OUR INFAMOUS MAKEOVER DAY.
THIS USED TO BE
YOUR LIVING ROOM,
BUT NOW IT HAS TURNED INTO...
THE FREDERIC FEKKAI SALON!
>> (cheering)
>> ARE YOU READY TO HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA GET?
>> YES!
>> MISS EUGENA, THE GIRL
THAT THINKS SHE'S BETTER
THAN EVERYBODY ELSE
NEEDS SOME HAIR, GIRL!
>> OH!
>> MISS JAEDA,
HALLE BERRY HAIR!
>> OH!
>> ARE WE READY?
>> YEAH!
>> SOME GIRLS EMBRACED
THEIR FIERCE NEW LOOK...
>> I'VE NEVER HAD BROWN HAIR.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A BLONDIE,
AND IT TURNED OUT BEAUTIFUL.
>> I THOUGHT THEY WERE GONNA
CHOP IT OFF AND SHAVE ME DOWN,
BUT I WAS PLEASED WITH
MY MAKEOVER.
>> GOD, THERE'S SO MANY
GOOD SHOTS.
I DON'T WANNA MISS 'EM.
>> WHILE OTHERS LONGED
FOR THEIR OLD LOCKS.
>> (sobbing)
I'M COUNTING DOWN TILL
I CAN GROW THIS THING BACK.
IF I GO HOME,
IT'S NOT GONNA BE THIS SHORT,
I GUARANTEE IT.
>> THERE'S SO MANY
SERIOUS THINGS IN LIFE.
>> I THINK, UM, JAEDA,
JUST GETTING RID
OF AL THAT HAIR,
MADE HER GO FROM SUBURBAN MOM
TO SUPERMODEL.
SUPER HOT.
>> GOOD.
>> AND WHEN MONIQUE'S WEAVE
WAS REMOVED,
SHE STARTED TO COME UNGLUED.
>> I DO NOT LIKE PEOPLE KNOWING
I HAVE A WEAVE.
THAT'S JUST ME.
>> YOU ARE GETTING
A FRESH HAIR WEAVE
BY A MASTER STYLIST.
>> (crying) I'M JUST--
SO MUCH FRUSTRATION,
AND THE ONLY THING
I CAN DO TO JUST, LIKE,
GET IT OFF MY MIND RIGHT NOW
IS JUST TO CRY THIS OUT.
>> TO SEE THESE YOUNG GIRLS,
WHO SUPPOSEDLY
WANTED TO BE HERE SO BADLY,
JUST KIND OF THROW IT OFF
AND SAY, "UGH, I DON'T LIKE IT,"
IT JUST DISGUSTS ME.
>> FOR THE GIRLS
IN THE "TOP MODEL" HOUSE,
LIVING WITH 13 ROOMMATES
CAN BE CHALLENGING ENOUGH,
BUT LIVING WITH MONIQUE
WAS TURNING INTO MAJOR DRAMA.
>> THE OTHER DAY,
ONE OF THE TWINS
STARTED EATING MY POTATO CHIPS,
SO I'M OPENING UP
ALL THE CABINETS
LOOKING FOR MY CHIPS,
AND THE CHIPS AREN'T THERE.
>> YOU GUYS,
WE NEED TO HAVE A MEETING.
MONIQUE JUST TOOK ALL OUR FOOD
AND POURED IT ALL OUT BECAUSE
SHE'S MAD BECAUSE SOMEBODY...
>> WHAT?
>> SOMEBODY ATE HER STUFF.
>> SO I TAKE ALL THE CHIPS OUT,
AND I START SMASHING 'EM
WITH MY FEET, AND I POUR 'EM ALL
IN THE TRASH CAN
SO NOBODY EATS AROUND HERE.
>> WE'RE, LIKE, HAVING NO FOOD.
>> WHAT?!
>> SHE TOOK EVERYTHING OUT,
STEPPED ON IT
AND THREW IT IN THE GARBAGE CAN.
>> WHAT?!
>> AND SHE SAID PEOPLE ARE
EATING HER FOOD, EVEN THOUGH
PREVIOUSLY EVERYONE IN THE HOUSE
PITCHED IN THE SAME MONEY
FOR THE SAME AMOUNT OF FOOD,
AND EVERYONE'S SUPPOSED TO EAT
ALL THE FOOD.
THERE WAS NO, LIKE,
ANYBODY'S FOOD.
>> I AM REALLY SCARED
THAT SOMEBODY'S GONNA GET HURT.
>> MONIQUE, WHY DID YOU
THROW AWAY EVERYBODY'S CHIPS?
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> BECAUSE WHEN I WENT
TO GO SEE MY DORITOS,
THEY WERE NOT THERE.
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS, MONIQUE.
REALLY?!
SHE KNOWS WHAT--EXACTLY WHAT
SHE'S DOING AND DOESN'T CARE.
THAT IS FREAKING PATHETIC.
>> IF YOU CANNOT SHARE,
THEN THERE'S NO REASON FOR US
TO ALL GET FOOD TOGETHER, OKAY?
>> WAIT, WAIT,
WHO'S NOT SHARING, BITCH?
>> WHERE ARE MY DORITOS?!
NICE MONIQUE--
THROWN OUT THE FREAKING WINDOW.
BITCH HAS CAME IN.
>> WHY AREN'T YOU WILLING
TO SHARE?
>> IT PISSES ME OFF!
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH SHARING...
>> BUT WHATEVER I CANNOT EAT,
>> MONIQUE, WHAT HAVE YOU--
FOOD THAT I HELPED PUT IN FOR,
IT MAKES ME MAD.
>> THERE'S FOOD THERE,
THERE'S FOOD THERE,
THERE'S FOOD THERE!
THERE'S FOOD EVERYWHERE!
THERE'S FOOD TO EAT!
YOU ARE NOT GONNA GO HUNGRY!
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HER AT ALL.
I'VE NEVER MET ANYONE LIKE HER.
I DON'T GET HER.
I DON'T WHY SHE DOES STUFF.
"HMM, SOMEONE ATE MY CHIPS,
SOMEONE ATE MY GRAPEFRUIT.
I COULD CONFRONT THEM,
OR I COULD THROW AWAY
ALL THEIR CHIPS."
>> SHE'S A PSYCHO.
>> NONE OF US WANT TO SEE
ANYBODY GO HOME EXCEPT MONIQUE,
BECAUSE SHE'S CRAZY
AND WE'RE, LIKE,
CAN'T LIVE WITH HER.
LIKE, SHE'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO LIVE WITH.
>> BUT THINGS REALLY GOT HAIRY
WHEN THE GIRLS HAD TO DO
A PHOTO SHOOT WEARING
ELABORATE WIGS AND WEAVES
FEATURED IN HAIR SHOWS.
THESE STREET STYLES HAVE
CROSSED OVER TO THE RUNWAY.
>> GIVE ME SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT SAFE.
>> AAH!
AAH!
>> CARIDEE AND MELROSE
WORKED IT.
>> YOUR SHOTS ARE SO POWERFUL.
OH, I'M--I'M REALLY HAPPY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SHOW ME WHAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH.
>> OOH, I LIKE THIS ONE!
>> MM-HMM.
>> LOOK AT THIS!
>> WHILE OTHERS SEEMED
A LITTLE OVERWHELMED
UNDERNEATH ALL THAT EXTRA HAIR.
>> DROP THE SHOULDER DOWN.
IT MAKES YOU LOOK
LONGER AND LEANER.
>> I'M TRYING TO THINK
OF EMOTIONS.
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO THINK
OF EMOTIONS,
OR DO YOU HAVE AN EMOTION?
IF IT'S REAL,
AND IT'S REAL HERE,
IT'S GONNA COME ACROSS.
>> I DIDN'T REALIZE
HOW HARD IT WAS TO SHOW
THE EMOTION IN YOUR FACE.
>> ALL I'VE GOT
FOR ABOUT 40 FRAMES
IS "WOMAN IN THE GREEN WIG."
>> AND WHAT YOU NEVER SAW
WAS MEGG'S MAJOR MELTDOWN.
>> I'M GONNA BE
REALLY HONEST WITH YOU--
IN THE LAST TWO SHOOTS,
I'VE REALLY STRUGGLED WITH YOU.
>> LIKE, I KNOW THIS IS GONNA
SOUND SO LAME, BUT, LIKE,
I LIKE TO BE MYSELF AND JUST
BE INTO MY HEAVY METAL MUSIC.
AND IT'S--THAT WAS, LIKE,
WHERE I GOT ONE
OF MY BIGGEST STRENGTHS FROM.
IT'S, LIKE, FROM MUSIC.
THAT'S WHAT WOULD HELP ME MODEL.
LIKE, I'D LISTEN
TO MY FAVORITE SONG
BEFORE I GO OUT,
AND THEN I'D BE ABLE
TO JUST WORK IT.
>> WORK IT.
AS A MODEL, YOU'RE GONNA BE
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
YOU CAN'T TURN
TO THE PHOTOGRAPHER AND SAY,
"OH, I CAN'T MODEL.
I DON'T HAVE MY ROCK MUSIC."
>> I NEVER CRY.
HERE, I FEEL SO VULNERABLE.
I JUST WANT TO PLAY
SOME BONGOS, MAN.
>> (laughs) YOU'RE SO CUTE!
OH, MY GOD!
>> TO HELP LIGHTEN THINGS UP,
THE GIRLS GOT TOGETHER
AND TRIED MAKING MUSIC,
"TOP MODEL"-STYLE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> MAKING A BONGO DRUM SET.
>> DO YOU PLAY THE DRUMS?
>> NO...
>> (laughs)
>> BUT I'M GONNA LEARN TODAY.
>> THAT'S PRETTY GOOD
FOR A BOX AND SOME FLOWERPOTS.
>> (laughs)
>> MEGG MADE BONGOS
OUT OF A CARDBOARD BOX.
LIKE, I CALLED THEM
THE GHETTO BONGOS.
>> LOOK AT THIS!
(laughs)
>> YESTERDAY, WHEN I CAME TO
MY REALIZATION AND ALL THAT,
LIKE, I FELT REALLY CRAPPY.
BUT THEN TODAY,
YOU KNOW, I MADE SOME BONGOS.
>> ♪ MEGG IS SO COOL... ♪
>> YEAH!
>> ♪ SHE BOUNCES AROUND ♪
♪ SHE GOT ♪
♪ HER GHETTO-ASS BONGOS... ♪
>> ♪ BONGOS... ♪
>> ♪ BUT SHE DON'T FROWN... ♪
>> ♪ BONGOS, BONGOS... ♪
(laughs)
YEAH, WE DON'T SOUND
ALL THAT GREAT,
BUT THE FACT THAT
WE'RE MAKING NOISE TOGETHER--
IT'S JUST FUN
TO CREATE DIFFERENT STUFF.
♪ WE GOT A BITCH ♪
>> ♪ SOME BITCHES ♪
♪ IN THIS HOUSE ♪
♪ BUT IT'S OKAY ♪
>> WE ALREADY HAVE
ENOUGH DRAMA GOING ON.
SOMEONE NEEDS
TO BRING THE PEACE.
THAT'S ME, BABY,
SO PEACE, LOVE,
ROCK 'N' ROLL MADNESS.
>> BUT THINGS GOT SERIOUS
WHEN IT WAS TIME TO DECIDE
WHO WOULD GET ELIMINATED.
YOU'RE NO LONGER
THE PRETTIEST GIRL IN SCHOOL,
AND I FEEL LIKE
IT'S GETTING TO YOU.
>> I JUST HAVE TO GET
USED TO IT.
>> UP NEXT IS MEGAN.
ALL RIGHT, MEGAN,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH CRAZY HAIR.
>> (high-pitched voice) BORING!
(normal voice) I NEED MORE NECK.
>> THIS IS NOT A GREAT PICTURE.
>> MEGAN'S PICTURE
DIDN'T SHOW THE JUDGES
SHE HAD TOP MODEL POTENTIAL...
>> SHE'S GOT A GREAT BODY,
SHE'S GOT THAT
GREAT BONE STRUCTURE,
BUT SHE HAS NOT BROUGHT IT
TO THIS PICTURE.
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
>> I DIDN'T EXPECT JAEDA
TO BE UP THERE.
I ACTUALLY EXPECTED MONIQUE
TO BE UP THERE WITH ME, WHICH--
I WAS SURPRISED.
>> IN THEIR NEXT CHALLENGE,
THE GIRLS LEARNED THAT
SOMETIMES BEING A TOP MODEL
IS LIKE WALKING A TIGHTROPE.
TO BE SUCCESSFUL,
YOU HAVE TO KEEP YOUR BALANCE.
>> WE'RE GONNA TEACH YOU GUYS
TO WALK THIS
HALF-INCH ROPE CABLE
>> OH, MY GOD, I CAN'T DO THIS!
♪♪
>> (laughs)
>> WHOO!
>> OKAY, NEXT.
>> I CAN'T EVEN
WALK A STRAIGHT LINE
WHEN I'M DEAD SOBER,
SO HELL IF I'M GONNA
WALK A LITTLE TINY ROPE.
>> GOOD!
>> I'M NEXT SO...
>> TAKE YOUR TIME.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
>> NOPE. NOPE, NOPE.
>> (whines)
>> READY?
GOOD. PERFECT.
LEAN FORWARD.
>> MELROSE QUICKLY
ESTABLISHED HERSELF
AS THE MOST FEARED COMPETITOR
WITH HER STEELY DETERMINATION.
>> MELROSE--SHE JUST ACTS LIKE
SHE'S JUST SO PERFECT,
AND SHE'S NOT.
>> PERFECT!
>> MONIQUE'S
JEALOUS ATTITUDE...
>> YOU DID GOOD!
>> (cheering)
>> YEAH, NICE!
>> WAS HAVING A NEGATIVE EFFECT
BACK AT THE HOUSE,
WHERE MONIQUE AND MELROSE
WEREN'T EXACTLY HITTING IT OFF.
>> BE CALM--
>> IT'S LIKE DEALING
WITH CHILDREN.
CAN YOU MOVE, PLEASE?
>> SHE JUST...
(door closes)
>> I JUST WANTED HER
TO LET ME HAVE MY SPACE.
>> BUT THINGS REALLY
STARTED HEATING UP
WHEN THEY TRIED
COOKING OVER THE SAME STOVE
IN THIS NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN
CATFIGHT.
>> MONIQUE, STOP!
>> IS THIS MY--
IS THIS MY TACO SEASONING?
>> STOP! WHAT'S--
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YOU'RE SO WEIRD!
PLEASE, JUST STOP!
OH, MY GOD, GET AWAY FROM ME!
>> (imitating Melrose)
"OH, MY GOD! OH, MY GOD,
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?"
>> SERIOUSLY,
YOU HAVE PSYCHOLOGICAL--
>> SERIOUSLY, LIKE,
YOU HAVE PSYCHOLOGICAL PROBLEMS.
>> YOU DO.
>> YEAH, YOU DO.
>> (grunts) YOU'RE SCARY.
>> "(grunts) YOU'RE SCARY."
>> (laughs)
WILL YOU PLEASE LEAVE?
YOU'RE--YOU'RE SCARING ME.
>> "PLEASE LEAVE,
YOU'RE SCARING ME."
>> NO, I NEED TO COOK DINNER.
>> "NO, I NEED TO COOK DINNER."
>> (laughs silently)
>> (laughs)
>> MONIQUE--
SHE'S VERY STRESSED OUT.
SHE CAN'T CONTROL HER EMOTIONS.
THIS MIGHT BE TOO MUCH FOR HER.
>> ADDING TO THE STRESS
WAS A CHALLENGE
THAT LEFT SOME GIRLS
BETWEEN A ROCK...
>> ROCK THE ROCKS
THAT YOU'RE WALKING ON, BABY!
>> AND A HARD PLACE.
>> WE'RE BASICALLY
WALKING BLIND ON COBBLESTONES.
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT. RECOVER.
>> WE BROUGHT BACK BRE,
THE CATWALK QUEEN FROM CYCLE 5,
TO HELP OUT.
>> VERY SEXY.
>> AND SHE'S HAD
ONE DRINK TOO MANY.
YES, SHE DID.
>> CARIDEE'S WALK
NEEDED A MAJOR OVERHAUL.
>> WHAT'S ALL THIS?
>> (snorts)
>> OKAY.
OH--OOH, YES, THE EXTRA TURN!
(grunts)
>> MM-HMM.
>> MISS MELROSE.
>> IN THE END,
MELROSE FAILED TO DELIVER
A PERFECT PERFORMANCE,
AND MONIQUE COULDN'T WAIT
TO RUB IT IN.
>> (imitates Melrose) "OH!
OH, MY GOD, I'M GOING TO DIE!"
>> BUT MONIQUE'S JOY
WAS SHORT-LIVED,
AS SHE STARTED TO FEEL ILL.
>> (normal voice) I WAS REALLY
STARTING TO GET SICK.
MY HEAD WAS, LIKE, HURTING,
LIKE, REALLY, REALLY BAD.
ONE MINUTE,
I'LL BE REALLY, REALLY HOT,
THEN THE NEXT MINUTE,
I'LL BE REALLY, REALLY COLD.
>> I JUST THINK
ALL THAT NEGATIVE ENERGY
SHE PUT OUT THERE
THOSE FIRST TWO WEEKS
IS BREEDING ON ITSELF.
MAYBE SHE REALLY
MADE HERSELF SICK.
>> MONIQUE IS GETTING
SICKER AND SICKER
BY THE HOUR.
>> I CAN'T KEEP NOTHING DOWN.
>> I'M KIND OF SCARED FOR HER,
AND I THINK SHE NEEDS
TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
WELL, HOPEFULLY,
THEY'LL FIND OUT
WHAT'S WRONG WITH HER
SO SHE'LL BE ABLE
TO PERFORM TOMORROW.
>> ON THE NEXT DAY'S
PHOTO SHOOT,
MONIQUE TRIED TO TOUGH IT OUT.
>> LIKE, MY HEART AND MY MIND
IS LIKE, "BE HERE,
AND STAY AND DO THIS,"
BUT MY BODY IS LIKE,
"YOU CAN'T."
>> IF YOU WANNA GO BACK
TO THE HOUSE,
I WILL HAVE THE DRIVER
COME AND PICK YOU UP
SO YOU CAN GO BACK TO SLEEP.
HEY, I WANT YOU TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION,
BUT YOU HAVE TO MAKE THAT
FOR YOURSELF.
>> I'LL JUST
TAKE THE THING HOME THEN.
>> YOU WANNA TAKE THE RIDE HOME?
OKAY.
>> MONIQUE CALLED IN SICK
WHILE THE REST OF THE GIRLS
TRIED TO WALK ON WATER
DOING A SLIPPERY PHOTO SHOOT.
>> IT, LIKE, STARTS TIPPING,
AND, LIKE, I ALMOST FALL IN.
>> CARIDEE SUFFERED FROM
OVEREXPOSURE...
>> HEY, IT'S FASHION, HONEY.
BOOBS DO PEEKABOO
IN FASHION SHOWS.
>> AND EUGENA
LOST HER SEA LEGS.
FROM FLOATING RUNWAYS
TO A RUNAWAY BIRD,
THERE HASN'T BEEN
A DULL MOMENT.
>> THERE'S A BIRD!
>> AAH!
(screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> HEY, LOOK--OH! OH, MY GOD!
NO, NO! NO, NO, NO!
>> AAH!
>> NO!
>> ANCHAL,
DON'T BREAK OUR HOUSE.
>> THERE IS IT, THERE IT IS.
GET IT.
>> BIRDIE.
>> OH, NO, NO, NO.
WRONG WAY. COME UP HERE.
(laughs)
(screams)
THERE YOU GO.
THERE YOU GO! GOOD BOY.
>> WHOO!
>> WE GOT IT.
>> AT JUDGING, THE PANEL
WAS LESS THAN IMPRESSED
WITH EUGENA'S PHOTO.
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME THAT
YOU'VE HEARD THE JUDGES SAY
THAT YOU'RE NOT CONNECTING
WITH YOUR EYES.
I WOULD'VE LIKED
TO SEE YOU HAVE MORE POWER.
YOU WERE LIKE, "OKAY,"
RATHER THAN, "OKAY."
BUT IT WAS MONIQUE'S ABSENCE
THAT WORRIED THE PANEL MORE.
THIS INDUSTRY DOESN'T CARE
IF YOU'RE SICK...
>> MNH-MNH.
>> THEY DON'T CARE
IF YOU ARE TIRED,
AND WE'RE BEING HARD BECAUSE
THIS IS THE REAL WORLD.
SO EUGENA SURVIVED...
EUGENA, WE KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE IT.
AND MONIQUE WAS SENT HOME.
>> I'M DONE HERE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
I FEEL LIKE
I KIND OF WASTED MY TIME
BEING HERE RIGHT NOW.
>> COMING UP--
MELROSE MOUTHS OFF...
>> AS THIS COMPETITION GOES ON,
SHE'S NOT BECOMING
MORE BEAUTIFUL TO ME.
>> AND LATER,
SHE GETS PUT IN HER PLACE.
>> THE WAY YOU COME OFF
TOWARDS ME,
I'M--I GET VERY FRUSTRATED
WITH YOU.
>> IN WEEK FIVE,
THE GIRLS GOT A CHANCE
TO KICK IT INTO HIGH GEAR
WITH SOME EXTREME POSING.
>> MY NAME IS STACEY McKENZIE,
AND I'M A MODEL,
AND I'M ALSO A JUDGE
FOR "CANADA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
SO TODAY, I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
A BIT OF IDEA ON HOW TO USE
YOUR EDGY QUIRKINESS
AND ALL OF THAT STUFF
INTO HIGH FASHION POSING.
>> SO I'LL TAKE A POSE
AND DO SOMETHING KIND OF LIKE...
THIS,
WHEREAS YOU MIGHT
TAKE SOMETHING AND TWIST IT
A LITTLE BIT LIKE THAT.
>> IT LOOKED LIKE ANCHAL HAD
A LEG UP ON THE COMPETITION...
>> I DISCOVERED
I WAS MORE FLEXIBLE
THAT I THOUGHT.
MY FEET WENT FROM
TOUCHING MY HEAD
TO BEING IN FRONT OF MY FACE.
>> BUT BACK AT THE HOUSE,
ANCHAL'S NEWLY FOUND CONFIDENCE
WAS CRUSHED.
>> WELL, INITIALLY,
I THOUGHT THAT SHE WAS
ONE OF THE STIFFEST
COMPETITIONS HERE, BUT AS THIS
COMPETITION GOES ON...
>> I REALLY THINK
>> SHE'S NOT BECOMING
SHE'S ONE OF THE WEAKEST, YEAH.
MORE BEAUTIFUL TO ME.
>> (crying)
I OVERHEARD MELROSE
TALKING ABOUT ME,
AND IT JUST KIND OF REALLY
FREAKIN' HURT ME.
IT JUST REALLY SUCKS
HOW MEAN THEY CAN BE.
>> THEN IT WAS TIME
TO STRIKE A POSE FOR REAL
DURING A CHALLENGE
THAT WOULD PUT ALL THE GIRLS
UP ON A PEDESTAL
FOR INNOVATIVE DESIGNER
BAO TRANCHI.
>> CHANGE.
>> MY MUSCLES
WERE LITERALLY SHAKING
LIKE A BOWL OF JELL-O.
>> SO I'M TRYING TO DO
A LOT OF POSES
THAT COMPLIMENTS MY BODY SHAPE.
>> I THINK THAT, UH,
THE GIRL WHO DESERVES
TO BE PUT ON A PEDESTAL...
WAS EUGENA.
>> (cheering)
>> THE NEXT MORNING,
I DROPPED BY THE HOUSE
FOR A TALK ABOUT FEARS
AND INSECURITIES.
IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT HAS MADE YOU FEEL INSECURE
AND IN SOME WAY INSTILLED
A FEAR INSIDE OF YOU?
>> I HEAR PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT ME IN THE HOUSE.
>> YOU TAKE IT IN
AND THEN YOU IGNORE IT,
BUT YOU SEE, YOU STORE IT INSIDE
AND IT EATS YOU UP.
>> I NEVER REALLY HAD FRIENDS.
I ALWAYS GOT MADE FUN OF,
AND NOBODY BELIEVES THAT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY I LOOK NOW,
BUT IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO BELIEVE IN MYSELF.
>> THIS INDUSTRY
IS A DOG-EAT-DOG INDUSTRY,
AND ALL OF YOU ARE COMPETING
FOR ONE PRIZE,
AND YOU CANNOT LET THAT GIRL
GET IN YOUR HEAD
AND TRY TO THROW YOU OFF BASE.
ALL RIGHT?
ALL RIGHT, I LOVE ALL Y'ALL.
GIVE ME A HUG.
>> WE LOVE YOU, TOO.
>> GIVE ME A HUG.
>> I HOPE AND PRAY
THAT TYRA DOESN'T SEE ME
AS THIS HORRIFYING PERSON,
BUT I DO FEEL
KIND OF SINGLED OUT IN THE GROUP
AS, LIKE, THE--THE MEAN ONE.
>> AFTER I LEFT,
MELROSE WAS FORCED
TO DEFEND HERSELF
IN THIS REVEALING,
UNSEEN MOMENT.
>> THE WAY YOU COME OFF
TOWARDS ME,
I'M--I GET VERY FRUSTRATED
WITH YOU, VERY FRUSTRATED.
>> I FEEL MISUNDERSTOOD HERE,
ESPECIALLY WITH YOUR SITU--
WITH THE SITUATION WITH ANCHAL.
>> I TRIED TO, LIKE,
GET TO KNOW YOU.
I TRIED, BUT YOU STILL COME OFF
WITH THIS, LIKE, ATTITUDE,
AND YOU SAY QUIRKY REMARKS
TO PEOPLE THAT JUST
KIND OF, LIKE, PISS PEOPLE OFF,
AND YOU IGNORE IT.
>> MAYBE THERE'S JUST A PART
OF ME YOU DON'T LIKE, YOU KNOW?
LIKE, THAT'S--THIS IS ME,
AND I CAN'T--
I CAN'T ACCELERATE AND CHANGE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO--
WHAT TO TELL YOU GUYS.
LIKE, WE ARE COMPETING
AGAINST EACH OTHER,
AND I AM NOT GONNA BE WALKED ON,
AND I WILL STICK UP FOR MYSELF,
AND I WILL DEMAND
THE SAME RESPECT THAT
I'M GONNA GIVE TO ALL OF YOU.
>> I'M SO OVER MELROSE
JUST BEING A BITCH.
IT'S UNCALLED FOR.
LIKE, SHE'LL JUST
MAKE LITTLE COMMENTS TO ME
ALL THE TIME,
AND I NEVER SAY ANYTHING BACK
'CAUSE I'M--
I'M BETTER ABOUT THAT.
LIKE, SHE'LL MAKE COMMENTS
ABOUT WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
TO OTHER PEOPLE AND IT'S LIKE,
"I WASN'T TALKING TO YOU.
I DON'T WANNA HEAR YOUR VOICE.
SHUT UP."
SHE'LL FIND WAYS TO JUST
PUT ME DOWN, LITTLE TINY THINGS
HERE AND THERE.
LITTLE, YOU KNOW, CUTS--
>> TILL SHE FEELS BETTER.
>> I KNOW, I KNOW,
AND IT'S LIKE...
>> IT'S LIKE, "I DIDN'T NEED
>> "I'M BETTER THAN THAT.
A POSITIVE--"
I'M BETTER THAN THAT.
I DON'T DO THAT TO YOU."
AND IT'S CHILDISH. SHE'S, LIKE,
THE OLDEST PERSON HERE.
IT'S SO CHILDISH.
>> I KNOW. ISN'T THAT FUNNY?
I WAS TOTALLY NOTICING THAT.
>> IT'S SO BAD.
IT'S LIKE, "WOW. WOW, GIRL."
>> AFTER CARIDEE
AND A.J. BONDED,
I SENT THE GIRLS
TO A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE CIRCUS SIDESHOWS
TOOK CENTER STAGE.
>> I WANT, LIKE,
A DARK SIDE TO THIS.
>> SOME GIRLS EMBRACED TURNING
INTO FASHIONABLE FREAKS.
>> I'M IN THIS METAL CAGE.
THERE'S BLOOD AND RAW MEAT
IN THERE.
IT'S A LITTLE SICK AND TWISTED,
WHICH IS KIND OF LIKE ME.
>> REMEMBER,
YOU GUYS ARE STUCK TOGETHER
ALL THE TIME.
>> OUR FREAK SHOW CHARACTER...
>> IS SIAMESE TWINS.
>> WE GET TO DO
A PHOTO SHOOT TOGETHER,
AND OUR HAIR LOOKS AWESOME.
>> PHEW, IT SMELLS.
DO YOU REALLY HAVE TO PAINT IT?
>> I'M LOOKING AT MYSELF LIKE,
"HI, YOU LOOK REALLY UGLY,"
BUT I KNOW THAT I HAVE
TO GO OUT THERE AND ROCK IT.
>> I LIKE YOUR VARIETY, MELROSE.
KEEP IT UP.
>> OTHERS STRUGGLED
WITH THE TRANSFORMATION.
>> (grunts)
>> YOU GOTTA MAKE SOME NOISE.
EITHER DO IT AND COMMIT TO IT,
OR DON'T.
>> (grunts)
>> AS THE BEARDED LADY,
MEGG HAD A TOUGH TIME
LETTING HER INNER BEAUTY
SHINE THROUGH.
>> WHY DON'T YOU IMPROVISE
ON A POSE?
WHAT WOULD MEGG DO?
>> IT'S ALL OVER FOR ME.
I'M LIKE A CRASHING AIRPLANE.
>> BUT A LITTLE LESS HARD,
A LITTLE MORE FEMININE.
>> LIKE, I REALLY WANT TO
TAKE THIS OFF, LIKE, RIGHT NOW.
LIKE, JUST, LIKE,
I CAN DO SO MUCH BETTER
AND, LIKE, I'M TOO WORRIED
ABOUT HAVING, LIKE, TO GET--
BE PERFECT AT IT,
AND IT DRIVES ME NUTS.
I REALLY WANT TO STOP,
BECAUSE I KNEW I-I HAVE, LIKE,
SUCH GOOD POTENTIAL
TO BE A GOOD MODEL, YOU KNOW?
>> MELROSE USED HER WRINKLES
IN HER SIDESHOW PHOTO
TO HER ADVANTAGE
AND SCORED POINTS
WITH THE PANEL.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT IT IS
YOU'RE STILL LIKE,
"I'M WRINKLED, BUT I'M SO HOT."
>> (laughs)
>> BY CONTRAST,
MEGG'S PHOTO FAILED TO IMPRESS.
>> YES, THE PERSONALITY'S
APPEALING.
YOU KNOW WHAT? IF YOU CAN'T
TAKE A GOOD PICTURE--
AND SHE HASN'T MANAGED
TO TAKE A GOOD PICTURE...
>> YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW,
THEN--THEN WHAT IS IT?
>> THE JUDGES DIDN'T SEE
TOP MODEL POTENTIAL,
AND MEGG WAS SENT HOME.
>> IT WAS REALLY HARD
SAYING GOOD-BYE.
IN A WAY, LIKE,
WE ALL HELD EACH OTHER TOGETHER
AND KEPT EACH OTHER ALIVE.
WHEN THERE'S SO MUCH
HATE GOING ON, IT'S SO HARD TO--
TO KEEP A POSITIVE ATTITUDE.
>> COMING UP--
THE GIRLS ELIMINATE
ONE OF THEIR OWN.
>> EIGHT BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME...
(passes gas)
(laughter)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> CARI FARTED!
>> IN WEEK SIX,
WITH ONLY NINE LEFT
IN THE COMPETITION,
STRESS LEVELS
WERE OFF THE CHART,
SO THE GIRLS GOT A CHANCE
TO CUT LOOSE AND HAVE SOME FUN.
>> WE'RE GONNA DO A FREE DANCE.
YOU'RE GOING TO WEAR A MASK,
AND YOU'RE GOING TO DANCE.
ALLOW YOURSELF
TO EXPRESS YOUR FEELINGS
THROUGH YOUR BODY.
NO PEEKING!
>> BACK AT THE HOUSE,
THE GIRLS STARTED GETTING
MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH EACH OTHER,
AND MICHELLE REALLY OPENED UP.
>> I DON'T TELL PEOPLE
WHO I LIKE, SO IF THAT'S ANY...
>> HAVE YOU EVER HAD
A BOYFRIEND?
>> NO.
I THINK PRETTY MUCH ALL MY LIFE
I'VE BEEN HIDING THAT
I DON'T KNOW WHO I AM.
I'M STILL FINDING MYSELF,
AND, LIKE, I'M FINALLY ABLE
TO ADMIT, LIKE, I HAVE NO IDEA.
I MIGHT BE GAY.
I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF I AM OR NOT.
>> YEAH.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW IF MICHELLE
ACTUALLY CAME OUT OF THE CLOSET,
BUT I THINK SHE'S
STRADDLING THE FENCE.
>> THEN IT WAS OFF
TO "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT,"
WHERE EVERYONE HAD TO LEARN
TO THINK ON THEIR FEET
AND COME UP WITH
SOME PROBING QUESTIONS
FOR "E.T." CORRESPONDENT
MARK STEINES.
>> I'M HERE TO TEACH YOU GUYS
BASICALLY WHAT
A GOOD INTERVIEW IS.
ASK A QUESTION, GET AN ANSWER.
>> CARIDEE WAS WITTY...
>> MARY-KATE AND ASHLEY?
OH, DOLCE & GABBANA.
VERY GOOD CHOICE.
>> "MARY-KATE AND ASHLEY."
>> MELROSE WAS A NATURAL...
>> HI, MARK.
>> HI! HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M MELROSE
FROM "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
HOW ARE YOU DOING TONIGHT?
>> I'M--I'M GOOD.
>> BROOKE'S DELIVERY
FELL FLAT...
>> SO, MARK,
HOW DID YOU GET YOUR START
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY?
>> YOUR QUESTIONS ARE COMING IN
LIKE YOU'VE REHEARSED THEM
AND YOU'VE STUDIED THEM.
BE YOURSELF.
>> UM...
>> AND A.J. JUST GAVE UP.
>> BACK AT THE HOUSE,
A.J.'s MOOD DARKENED.
>> I GO BACK AND FORTH
ALL THE TIME
ABOUT ACCEPTING MY FATE
AS A PERSON IN THIS HOUSE.
I'M HAVING MIXED FEELINGS
ABOUT DOING WELL
IN THIS COMPETITION.
IT JUST FILLS ME WITH THIS
OVERWHELMING DEPRESSION.
IT'S LIKE SOMETHING BROKE,
AND I CAN'T FIX IT.
>> SHE GOES UNDER THE WATER
FROM TIME TO TIME.
>> A.J.'s HARD TO READ
BECAUSE SHE HAS, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, MOOD SWINGS,
AND SHE HAS THIS, YOU KNOW,
DARK SIDE TO HER.
>> HONESTLY,
I'M SICK OF A.J.'s COMPLAINING.
SHE HAS SUCH A PESSIMISTIC VIEW
TOWARDS SO MUCH OF LIFE.
IT'S HARD TO DEAL WITH.
>> THE NEXT DAY
BROUGHT A NEW TEST.
>> I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO DO MY JOB
AND WORK THE RED CARPET.
>> THEIR ASSIGNMENT
WAS QUITE A CHALLENGE--
A SCARY INTERVIEW
WITH SUPERMODEL DIVA JANICE.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> I'VE SEEN HER
JUST KIND OF BEING, LIKE...
NOT A BITCH, BUT KIND OF LIKE--
YEAH, LIKE, KIND OF A BITCH.
>> I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
WHAT MAKES JANICE DICKINSON
JANICE DICKINSON?
WHAT MAKES YOU SO, YOU KNOW,
OVER... I--PUNGENT?
>> "OVERPUNGENT"?
>> OOH, OOH... (groans)
>> A.J. FROZE
UNDER THE HOT LIGHTS...
>> SO, UM...
I'M FORGETTING MY QUESTION
RIGHT NOW.
>> DON'T EVER FORGET. INVENT.
>> AND JAEDA GOT TONGUE-TIED.
>> SO, UM...
DAMN!
>> GIVE ME THE MIKE! BYE!
WHOO-HOO, I'VE GOT THE MIKE!
>> ONCE AGAIN,
MELROSE STOLE THE SPOTLIGHT...
>> WHAT MADE YOU
THE ORIGINAL SUPERMODEL?
>> WELL, I COINED THE TERM
BACK IN 1979.
>> VERY GOOD, VERY GOOD.
>> (laughs)
>> AND SHE RACKED UP
ANOTHER CHALLENGE VICTORY...
>> MELROSE.
>> YAY!
>> RAISING THE STAKES
AND MAKING HER RIVALS
EVEN MORE JEALOUS.
>> MELROSE'S REACTION
IS BASICALLY LIKE EVERYTHING
MELROSE DOES--OVEREXAGGERATED
AND, LIKE, "OH, MY GOD!"
>> THE NEXT DAY,
I MADE A SURPRISE VISIT
TO THE HOUSE
AND SPENT A LITTLE QUALITY TIME
ONE-ON-ONE.
>> OH, MY GOD, IT'S TYRA.
>> OH, MY--OH, MY GOD!
(laughter)
>> DO YOU THINK THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE INTIMIDATED BY YOU?
>> YEAH, I FEEL LIKE THEY JUST
DON'T WANT ME AROUND THEM,
AND A LOT OF MY LIFE,
JUST TRYING TO BE CONFIDENT--
AND MAYBE
OVERLY BEING CONFIDENT--
MIGHT PUSH PEOPLE AWAY
AND MIGHT BE LIKE,
"UGH," YOU KNOW?
>> ARE YOU SCARED
TO BE VULNERABLE?
>> YEAH, I'M SCARED...
BUT I'M STRONG.
>> I SEE, LIKE,
SUCH A STRONG DESIRE
IN YOUR FACE,
AND I'M WONDERING
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR HEAD
WHEN I'M LOOKING AT YOU
LIKE THAT.
>> I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO MODEL,
AND UNTIL, LIKE,
THREE MONTHS AGO
I HAD A SKIN DISEASE
THAT COVERED 78% OF MY BODY...
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> CALLED PSORIASIS.
IT'S A REALLY EMOTIONAL THING,
'CAUSE I ALWAYS WANTED TO MODEL,
AND I ALWAYS GOT TURNED DOWN.
>> WELL, NOW YOU'RE DOING IT.
>> YEAH.
>> AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
THE GIRLS GOT A TASTE
OF WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE FAMOUS.
>> TODAY,
YOU GIRLS ARE GOING TO BE
CELEBRITY COUPLES.
(laughter)
>> BUT BEING BOTH HALVES
OF A CELEBRITY COUPLE
DEMANDED DOUBLE THE EFFORT.
>> WHAT WERE GONNA DO
IS SHOOT YOU ONCE,
SEND YOU BACK TO HAIR AND MAKEUP
AND THEN SHOOT YOU AGAIN.
>> CARIDEE AS "BRANGELINA"...
>> EUGENA AS JAY-Z...
>> ♪ YEAH, YEAH ♪
>> AND BEYONCé.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> BUT A.J. SUFFERED
AN IDENTITY CRISIS
TRYING TO PRETEND
SHE WAS J.LO's MARC ANTHONY.
>> THIS ISN'T ME.
HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO BE LATINO?
(laughs)
OR MEXICAN OR WHATEVER.
OH, MY GOD.
(groans)
>> AND WHILE JAEDA'S
BOBBY BROWN WAS A HIT,
HER WHITNEY HIT A SOUR NOTE.
>> JAEDA AS WHITNEY?
I DON'T KNOW
IF I BELIEVE IT 100%.
>> TIRED OF BEING
IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
JAEDA STAGED
A JUDGING OF HER OWN.
>> OKAY, GO.
>> EIGHT BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME.
ONLY SEVEN OF YOU WILL CONTINUE.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
EUGENA.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU ARE STILL IN THE RUNNING
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
(laughter)
♪♪
>> PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SO, YOU KNOW, BOTH OF YOU
LOOK VERY MUCH ALIKE...
(laughter)
>> BUT EACH OF YOU HAS
YOUR OWN PERSONALITY,
WHICH IS GREAT.
(laughter)
>> MICHELLE, YOU TALK
A LITTLE FAST AT TIMES.
AMANDA, YOU'RE A LITTLE MORE
SOFT-SPOKEN.
BUT ONLY ONE OF YOU
MAY CONTINUE--
(passes gas)
(laughter)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> CARI FARTED!
>> THE NAME
I AM GOING TO CALL...
(laughter)
>> MICHELLE.
>> (faux sobbing)
>> THANK YOU, AMANDA.
>> (laughs)
>> IT'S FUNNY!
>> AT THE REAL JUDGING,
JAEDA'S PHOTO
DIDN'T CONVINCE THE PANEL
SHE WAS TOP MODEL MATERIAL...
>> IN THE WHITNEY HOUSTON SHOT,
THE EYES LOOK A LITTLE WORRIED.
>> GOTTA GET OVER YOUR FEAR,
MY DEAR.
>> AND SHE LANDED IN
THE BOTTOM TWO
FOR THE THIRD TIME.
JAEDA, YOUR PICTURES
HAVEN'T BEEN SO STRONG.
BUT IT WAS A.J.'s INDIFFERENCE
THAT FINALLY DID HER IN.
BEING A MODEL IS MORE THAN
JUST LOOKING LIKE ONE.
IT'S ABOUT
WANTING TO BE ONE, TOO.
BOBBY BROWN
SAVED YOUR BUTT, JAEDA.
AND A.J. WAS SENT HOME.
>> I CAME INTO THIS THING
NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO
WITH MY LIFE...
>> BYE.
>> THANK YOU.
AND HOPEFULLY THIS HAS GIVEN ME
A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF A DIRECTION, YOU KNOW, UM...
THAT MAYBE I COULD
PURSUE MODELING AS A CAREER.
UM... I AT LEAST KNOW NOW
THAT IT'S AN OPTION.
>> COMING UP,
I GIVE THE GIRLS A CHANCE
TO REALLY SCARE ME.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA
HOW SCARY YOU LOOK RIGHT NOW.
I'M LIKE, "JAEDA..."
>> IN THEIR SEVENTH WEEK,
I WANTED TO SEE THE GIRLS
IN ACTION,
SO I PICKED UP MY CAMERA
TO CAPTURE THEIR WILD SIDE
IN THIS SCARY/SEXY PHOTO SHOOT.
THE MOOD THAT
I'M LOOKING FOR IS ANGRY,
ALMOST KIND OF EVIL,
BUT STILL MAINTAINING
THAT SEX APPEAL.
>> OOH-OH.
>> (laughs)
>> I'M SO READY.
I'M READY TO BE...
(whispers) SCARY.
>> I LOVE ALL THESE ANGLES
YOU'RE GIVING ME.
NICE, SLOW DOWN.
YOU HAVE TO PAUSE AND THEN MOVE.
THERE YOU GO.
INTENSE.
I NEED TO FEEL THE INTENSITY.
NICE.
WHEN YOU DO THE--ANY ANGER,
KEEP IT IN YOUR EYES
AND JUST A LITTLE MOUTH.
THERE YOU GO.
I NEED YOU TO THINK ANGRY.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA
HOW SCARY YOU LOOK RIGHT NOW.
I'M LIKE, "JAEDA..."
BE SCARY, LIKE... (hisses)
PUT A LITTLE BIT OF TENSION
INTO YOUR ARMS,
LITTLE TENSION INTO YOUR HANDS,
NOT YOUR SHOULDERS.
>> SEXY/SCARY IS FUN, YOU KNOW.
IT'S DARK, IT'S DEEP,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IT'S HOT.
>> (growls)
THEN I SENT THE GIRLS
TO WORLD-RENOWNED
BURLESQUE QUEEN
DITA VON TEESE
FOR A LESSON
IN SUBTLE SEXINESS.
>> YOU NEVER WANT TO LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE TRYING TOO HARD,
AND EVERYTHING SHOULD BE SUBTLE.
IT SHOULD LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE JUST NATURALLY SEXY.
>> FOR SOME GIRLS,
BEING SEXY WAS A SNAP.
>> YEAH, GIRL!
WHOO!
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, THAT'S ENOUGH.
>> OTHERS HAD A TOUGH TIME
LEARNING HOW TO WORK IT.
>> WHOO!
WORK IT, BABY!
I HAVE TO BE SEDUCTIVE AND SEXY.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
I NORMALLY AM.
>> BROOKE HAD A DIFFICULT TIME,
AND SHE SEEMED
THE MOST NERVOUS OF EVERYONE
TO BE SEXY.
>> THE NEXT DAY
WHEN DINNER WAS SERVED,
THE GIRLS WERE ON THE MENU.
>> MY NAME IS CATHY GOULD,
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT.
>> HEY!
>> BEHIND ME
IS A DINING ROOM TABLE THAT WILL
TURN INTO A RUNWAY SHOW
THIS EVENING.
>> WHEN IT WAS SHOWTIME,
SOME GIRLS STEPPED IT UP.
>> I GET OUT THERE,
AND I'M JUST FEELING
REALLY GOOD.
>> OTHERS STUMBLED.
>> I WASN'T WORRIED I WAS GONNA
STEP ON ANYBODY'S FOOD
UNTIL I ROLLED MY ANKLE,
'CAUSE THEN AT THAT MOMENT
I THOUGHT I MIGHT FALL
ON EVERYBODY'S FOOD.
>> ANCHAL DOES NOT HAVE
A TYPICAL RUNWAY BODY.
SHE HAS MORE OF, LIKE,
A SWIMSUIT BODY.
>> BROOKE'S PERFORMANCE
WAS FAR FROM PERFECT.
>> I HAD TO FOCUS THE WHOLE TIME
ON STAYING ENGAGED
AND NOT ON UNCOMFORTABLE I WAS.
>> MELROSE SCORED
ANOTHER CHALLENGE VICTORY.
>> COME ON OVER HERE.
>> I WON THE CHALLENGE!
I WON, I WON.
YEAH, GIRLS!
>> SHE GOES,
"OH! OH, MY GOD! OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD!" AND DOES
HER LITTLE MELROSE THING.
SHE'S, LIKE, OVER-SUPER BUBBLY.
>> AND ANCHAL'S SELF-CONFIDENCE
TOOK ANOTHER HIT.
>> I USED TO BE SO SKINNY, CARI.
I USED TO BE
LIKE MELROSE-SKINNY.
THEN I STARTED GAINING WEIGHT
BECAUSE I GOT REALLY DEPRESSED
IN, LIKE, MIDDLE SCHOOL
>> AND THEN ONCE YOU START--
AND HIGH SCHOOL.
>>YEAH.
>> I WANNA BE HERE.
I'VE COME SO FAR.
I DON'T WANNA
LET THIS OPPORTUNITY GO.
I WANNA PROVE TO MYSELF
I CAN DO THIS.
LIKE, I TRY EATING
A GOOD BREAKFAST IN THE MORNING,
NOT, LIKE, A FATTY BREAKFAST.
>> YOU GOTTA STOP
FRYING UP THAT SAUSAGE.
CONCENTRATE ON EATING BETTER,
YOU'LL FEEL BETTER...
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> AND THEN YOUR BODY
WILL FOLLOW.
YOU KNOW, IT'S YOUR MIND FIRST.
MIND FIRST.
>> OH, CARI, I LOVE YOU.
>> THE NEXT MORNING,
THINGS GOT REALLY STEAMY
DURING A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH THE ROMANCE NOVEL KING
HIMSELF--FABIO.
>> OOH, THAT'S PRETTY.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY KIDS, FABIO?
>> NO.
>> DO YOU HAVE A WIFE?
>> NOPE, SINGLE.
>> NO? SINGLE MAN.
NO WONDER YOU DO SO MANY
ROMANCE COVERS.
NO ONE--NO ONE
TO TEAR YOU AWAY FROM THEM.
>> ANCHAL AND FABIO
WERE ON FIRE.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> I CAN'T LET MY SHYNESS
OR MY LOW SELF-ESTEEM
GET IN THE WAY
AND JUST MAKE ME BE LIKE,
OH, NO, I DON'T WANNA DO THIS.
AND PLUS, IT'S FABIO,
SO I HAVE TO IMPRESS.
>> BUT BROOKE'S PHOTO SHOOT
JUST RAN OUT OF STEAM.
>> WHEN YOU'RE LEANING IN,
I DON'T WANT YOU
TO LOSE YOUR NECK.
NOW I DON'T WANT YOU
TO START THINKING
MECHANICALLY ABOUT THIS.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE TRYING
TO FIND CALM
IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL THIS PANIC.
PUT YOUR HAND UP HIGHER.
>> AT JUDGING,
BROOKE WAS CRITICIZED
FOR HER INHIBITIONS...
SHE SHOULD'VE MOVED MORE.
SHE SHOULD'VE
FELT THE STORY MORE
INSTEAD OF JUST GOING INSIDE,
LIKE, "I'M SAD. I'M POOR.
LOVE ME."
>> I JUST SEE UNCOMFORTABLENESS.
>> AND BROOKE WAS ELIMINATED.
>> (sobbing)
IT'S JUST HARD BECAUSE
I WANT THIS SO MUCH MORE
THAN--I THINK--
ALMOST ANY OF THOSE GIRLS.
>> NOW ONLY
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN--
MELROSE, THE BOLD BEAUTY
WITH AN EYE FOR FASHION
FROM SAN FRANCISCO...
EUGENA, THE SEXY SIREN
WHO SIZZLES ON THE RUNWAY
FROM PALMDALE, CALIFORNIA...
A "TOP MODEL" FIRST--
MICHELLE, THE LONG, TALL TOMBOY
AND HER PHOTOGENIC TWIN AMANDA
FROM ANAHEIM, CALIFORNIA...
CARIDEE, THE STUNNER
FROM FARGO, NORTH DAKOTA,
WITH THE SUPERSIZED
PERSONALITY...
ANCHAL, THE GENTLE,
BREATHTAKING BEAUTY
FROM HOMESTEAD, FLORIDA...
AND JAEDA,
THE STATUESQUE STUDENT
FROM PARKERSBURG, IOWA.
DON'T MISS A MOMENT
WHEN WE FIND OUT
WHICH ONE OF THEM WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.